bon puisque c'est comme ça vous croyez
aux astres on va faire une interview
croyances on bouge quand holding ont peu
bougé par le génial
il n'ya pas pascal bruckner je crois
qu'il arrive c'est bruno pascal keller
réflexion février bruner qui vient dé
bon ben c'est bruckner va parler du
bonheur justement logiciel il en parlait
la vie moderne et j'y arrive pas est ce
que vous voyez est ce que vous croyez à
l'amour oui vient chez nous c'est même
ce qui est plus important parce que tout
ce qui va mal dans le monde vient de
gens qui dans leur enfance
on était carencée en amour authentique
parce qu'il ya plein de falsification de
l'amour même il ya des tas de parents
qui n'aiment pas leurs enfants
enfin il croit qu'il est mais en fait
ils ne l'aiment pas et je vous voyez en
vous ces structures
je voyais en dieu
dieu c'est un mot mais mais ce qu'il ya
derrière ce mot oui je vous croyais au
hasard finalement pas tant que ça je te
croyais au petit signe du destin par
exemple frédéric ont raconté tout à
l'heure son rêve il était sur un taxi
avec samy naceri ya pascal bruckner et
nombreux nerfs dans l'émission oui sinon
je vous promets aux mauvais esprits avec
un sav canesse mais il ya des théories
qu'ils sont très intéressantes qui
veulent que que certains êtres qui sont
morts donc et qui sont restés trop
attaché au matériel à la matière reste
très proche de la terre et sont assez
néfaste
je sais pas ce que ça vaut gardiens je
ne sais pas je crois qu'il ya des forces
invisibles qui nous qui peut-être nous
protège
je pense on est guidé aussi par
on est guidé par ce que l'on peut croire
à des choses sans rentrer dans des
tripes mystique ou quoi mais c'est aussi
ce qui nous fait ce qui nous fait
avancer tous les jours moi je sais que
je crois c'est un choix je crois aux
gens qui par exemple vous on vous ont
aimé même s'ils sont plus là et le fait
de vous continuez à les aimer ça vous
fait avancer donc je pense pas il me
regardant aux moyens moi je continue à
aimer sûr là je parle par exemple pour
une personne appréciée aujourd'hui vous
voyez la télépathie ah oui je pense
qu'il peut y avoir effectivement
l'homéopathie ah oui les guesh patti j'y
crois aussi bon qu'est ce que vous
voulez là comme récompense pour avoir
bien répondu à toutes ses questions
voulait le triomphe romain la forêt vous
aimez la forêt marie laffont non la
forêt partir dans la forêt oui vous
allez faire mais ça ne va pas du tout si
une forêt très calme sous bois de
boulogne à l'arrêt chez vous scheer mais
les yeux
est ce que tout le monde peut fermer les
yeux sur le plateau j'ai dû fermer les
yeux tout le monde ferme les yeux fermés
les yeux on part en forêt
voilà c'était notre petite minute dans
la forêt ça vous a plu
on va tous nous on n'est ce pas monsieur
prévost mais moi j'aime beaucoup c'est
bien la forêt oui j'ai reconnu notre
petit oiseau on rallume